since 9/11 the US has spent trillions of
dollars and thousands of American lives
trying to remake the Middle East in our
image it's sad to say it out loud but we
have to it hasn't worked many of us
thought it would but it hasn't by every
measure our foreign wars have ended in
dismal failure for the United States
however noble their intentions and some
did have noble intentions Donald Trump
was one of the rare Republican
politicians honest enough to admit this
he said it out loud three years ago and
promised not to repeat the same mistakes
if elected president partly because he
said that he was elected president
now something fast things happening the
very people in some cases literally the
same people who lured us into the Iraq
quagmire 16 years ago
are demanding a new war this one with
Iran the President to his great credit
appears to be skeptical of this very
skeptical Iran recently downed an
unmanned American drone the president
speaking today seem to suggest this
shouldn't necessarily trigger a conflict
with Iran watch Iran made a big mistake
this drone was in international waters
clearly we have it all documented I
would imagine it was a general or
somebody that made a mistake in shooting
that drone down and fortunately that
drone was unarmed it was not there was
no man in it and there was no it was
just it was over international waters
clearly over international waters but we
didn't have a man or woman in the drone
we had nobody in the drone would have
made a big difference let me tell you
what it made a big big difference I find
it hard to believe it was intentional if
you want to know the truth I think that
it could have been somebody who was
loose and stupid that did it so that's
not nearly bellicose enough for the
permanent foreign policy establishment
in Washington many of whom crave a war
with the wrong and see every provocation
as an opportunity to start one Senator
Lindsey Graham for example says
Americans ought to be ready to fight and
die for shipping lanes on the other side
of the world watch so here's what to
watch for if the Iranians follow through
on their threat to start enriching again
at higher levels to basically
take their enrichment program to a kind
of a nuclear level in terms of a
weapons-grade production Israel's in a
world of hurt so the best thing the
president can do is stop that and how do
you stop that to make Iran understand
you're not going to let that happen I
think you should put their oil
refineries on our target list that they
should look at sinking the Iranian Navy
if they attack shipping again so in
Washington there are no real
consequences for being wrong and as a
result policy makers are they make the
same mistakes again and again and it's
certainly not just Lindsey Graham at the
New York Times left-wing warmonger Brett
Stevens is also calling on America to
sink the Iranian Navy many on the left
are for it john bolton cheers him on
from within the White House Bill Kristol
nods with approval from outside the
White House none of these people will
admit their actual intentions let's say
they don't really want a war with Iran
that's a crock
they want a war badly badly enough to
lie about it that's why they're putting
American troops into situations where
conflict is inevitable in order to start
a war everyone in washing knows exactly
what's happening they've seen it many
times before